[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci d'être avec nous
pour cette émission exceptionnelle que
je vous propose ce matin sur france 3
centre val de loire
nous allons rejoindre en tramway en
quartier en plein renouveau au coeur de
tours tout près de la loire qu'on
traverse justement je vous propose de
découvrir un bâtiment emblématique qui
vient de voir le jour le centre de
création contemporaine
olivier debré un lieu de vie de
rencontres de culture et d'art que je
vous propose de découvrir en
avant-première suit les moyens ce lieu
le mois ci le bâtiment a été conçu par
les architectes portugais high res
matthaus il est en pierre de taille
pierre de trc originaire de la vienne
c'est un édifice de 4500 m² percer
depuis lumière un édifice très pur fait
de plans et de vide vous allez le
découvrir dans quelques instants
[Musique]
situé en bord de loire le centre de
création contemporaine olivier debré va
ouvrir ses portes au public cet après
midi le bâtiment lui s'inscrivent dans
un grand chantier de rénovation de
l'entrée de la ville il incarne aussi
cette volonté d'intégrer lé architecture
contemporaine au coeur historique de
tours l'occasion pour nous de revenir
sur l'histoire et l'évolution de ce
quartier avec arnaud moreau et amélie
rigodanzo
d'ici quelques mois la place anatole
france en bord de loire arborera un
nouveau visage en plus du ccco des deux
hôtels de luxe à l' architecture
contemporaine vont sortir de terre
de quoi redonner un nouveau souffle à ce
quartier peu de gens le savent mais il
fut il ya plus d'un siècle
un pôle très important de la ville il
abritait même jusqu aux années 1900 la
mairie et le palais de justice dès le
xvème siècle sera aménagé lax de la rue
nationale
c'est là que tout va changer lorsque cet
espace est réhaussée cette nouvelle voie
deviennent nouvelles entrées dans la
ville une entrée très forte elle va
complètement reconstruire la centralité
de la ville de tours qui va basculer
destouesse tout est ouest vers nord-sud
et c'est l'axé nord-sud qui va devenir
le nouvel acte du développement de
l'agglomération avec cette fameuse
percée de la tranchée dit de la tranchée
pour arriver ici et descendre vers
bordeaux
cette nouvelle architecture
contemporaine qui va arriver dans le
quartier ne bouleversera pas les
habitudes en effet sur trois kilomètres
carrés
tous les styles se côtoient du moyen-âge
à la renaissance en passant par le
moderne
tout est un cas original
cet empilement cette stratification
cette présence stratifié de l'histoire
urbaine est plutôt rare puisqu'en fait
jusqu'à maintenant on n'avait pas peur
de détruire pour reconstruire pensons
tout simplement à paris où tous qui
avons re semaine n'a disparu d'une
certaine par sursaut dans certains
endroits
si la construction de deux hôtels de
luxe ne fait pas l'unanimité à tour le
renouveau du quartier va apporter une
dynamique notamment au commerce
la place anatole france va donc devenir
la nouvelle porte de la ville ouverte
sur la culture et le monde les portes
c'est là que le marché se mettait à la
porte parce que c'était le lieu de
rencontre de l'intérieur et l'extérieur
donc le lieu où là la plus grande
présence d d d d d acheteurs étaient
possibles jean nouvel avec le vin si
victor laloux avec la gare la mairie et
la basilique saint martin désormais les
portugais high res et matthaus avec le
cc cod pour ne citer qu'eux l'histoire
d'amour entre la ville de tours et les
architectes n'est pas prête de s'arrêter
je me trouve maintenant dans la plus
grande salle de ce centre de création
contemporaine
la grande galerie blanche avec autour de
moi des oeuvres de celui qui a donné son
nom à ce centre olivier debré est avec
moi pour en parler alain julien la feria
bonjour beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes le directeur de ce centre
alors on dit bien centre de création
contemporaine est amusé c'est important
tout à fait nous on s'occupe de
l'apparition de l'art de trouver des
connivences entre les oeuvres les
époques les artistes un musée
prioritairement s'occupe des oeuvres
d'art c'est pas tout à fait pareil vous
avez bien est-il une donation celle
d'olivier debré ça représente quoi
la donation représente les grands très
grands tableaux de lier debré qui sont
parmi les plus grands sinon les plus
grands tableaux de la peinture
contemporaine française
ils font 9 mètres sur 4 nous les avions
commandés à l'occasion de son exposition
91 à la dimension de nos murs il avait
souhaité qu'on en hérite à vous parliez
de ses grands formats y en a un qui nous
saute aux yeux évidemment quand on
rentre dans cette pièce c'est cet
immense toile bleue 9 mètres sur 4 vous
l'avez dit ça c'est la loire selon
olivier debré c'est ça
alors c'est un peu un peu schématique à
la fois tout à fait vrai c'est la loire
dans la mesure où il est les peindre en
bord de loire
comme disait un critique d'art célèbres
de l'époque il avait toujours les pieds
dans la loire est donc ce tableau c'est
effectivement le mouvement de la loi
mais c'est surtout mouvements de son
corps il balayait que ces grands
pinceaux ses grands bals et la couleur
pour la faire partir pour laisser juste
la trace mais et garder des matières
tout à coup il s'arrêter on ne sait pas
pourquoi il gardait des matières il
avait quelques francs chercher ailleurs
comme le vert que vous voyez là qui
vient s'opposer aux roses est derrière
d'ailleurs ces mêmes papa il a laissé la
toile libre et l'a finalement sénile de
la loire c'est à dire c'est ce qui est
formidable dans ce fleuve c'est qu'il le
fleuve laisse des îles aux arbres dont
qu'ils puissent pousser donc là c'est
une peinture en mouvement absolue d'une
liberté incroyable et pourtant il ya des
endroits qui ne couche pas c'est une
toile qu'on a pas vu en france depuis
1991 depuis votre commande en fait tout
à fait ce tableau une histoire
particulière c'est qu'à l'issue de là
l'explosion qu'on ait fait la banque
européenne d'investissement luxembourg
le directeur de la fondation avait
souhaitait l'acquérir
donc elle est parti immédiatement après
l'exposition au luxembourg et n'a plus
jamais réparer ou la vie de bree il a
beaucoup voyagé ici pour l'inauguration
de ce centre vous avez vous lu parlé de
ses voyages et surtout parlé de la
norvège où il a beaucoup voyagé
voilà on est parti de tous ses petits
carnets de dessins magnifiques vous riez
au centre dans les vitrines et à partir
de là on a on a vu qu'il avait
énormément pas dans plein de sites en
norvège
donc nous avons réuni les meilleures
collections les meilleurs près des plus
grands musées des plus grandes
collections privées pour offrir aux
tourangeaux et aux français
une oeuvre qui est quasiment inédite
pour ses tableaux n'ont jamais été vus
par les français merci beaucoup pour
cette explication a justement continuer
de s'intéresser à olivier debré avec un
portrait signé arnaud moreau
grand amateur de la nature olivier debré
a eu un rapport fusionnel avec la loire
il réalisera sans fin des
représentations de paysages peut être
influencée au départ par son grand père
le peintre edouard debat-ponsan
[Musique]
après sa rencontre avec picasso c'est là
où il va vraiment se diriger vers à
l'abstraction écrit des oeuvres plutôt
géométriques travaillées au couteau par
de grands aplats comme ici cette grande
grise qui date de 1957
il va se diriger dans les années 60
vers une matière beaucoup plus fluide
plus en adéquation avec aussi le paysage
et surtout les paysages de loi très
liquides très fluide avec de très grands
formats qui permet non seulement au
peintre d'être dans le paysage mais au
spectateur d'entrer directement dans le
paysage qu'est la toile
et voici là où vivait olivier debré à
vernou sur brenne en touraine à deux pas
de la loire son fils patrice a laissé
l'atelier tel quel depuis 1999 et la
mort de l'artiste
on y trouve donc des toiles parfois
inachevé certaines monumentales ainsi
que la fidèle compagne du peintre
si la voiture qui le prenaient pour
aller pas donc ils partaient avec cette
voiture jaune y avait souvent ma bonne
étoile sur le toit en plus des toiles
dans le coffre
et puis il est allé tout ses toiles au
bord de la loire ille sur têt les balais
et souhaitait apam et la voyez ce qui
est amusant vous trouvez la fiche en
livraison de tableau de marque
mais la loire n'est pas la seule à avoir
inspiré olivier debré il ya aussi la
norvège
il s'est rendu à plusieurs reprises
arpentant le pays dans tous les sens
surtout la région des fjords il
apprécier vraiment les variations il et
j'ai le changement duo saison certaines
peintures sont faites en automne toutes
ses couleurs sans fatigue et le pays a
tout de suite été conquis le considérant
dès le départ comme l'un des plus grands
peintres français de son époque
chaque fois que ces tables ont été
commercialisés tous est toujours vendue
et critique d'art et les journalistes
ont systématiquement écrit des choses
positives sur son intérêt olivier debré
inlassable voyageur a également
travaillé en amérique du sud et du nord
mais aussi en asie
il y à réaliser des oeuvres monumentales
sur lesquels ils marchaient comme par
exemple le rideau de l'opéra de shanghai
mais partout où aller le peintre et
quoique voyait ses yeux il gardait
toujours un peu de loire en lui
[Musique]
et pour continuer de décrypter l'oeuvre
d'olivier debré marine au charme à
rejoindre jean marine
vous êtes chargé d'exposition au ccc aux
dés vous êtes surtout une grande
connaisseuse de l'oeuvre d'olivier debré
on a ici des tableaux de son premier
voyage culturel en norvège c'est ça oui
c'est ça il y allé plusieurs fois en
la visite est de nombreux endroits et
donc ça c'est un des exemples des
endroits qu'il a visité ce sont les
lofoten c'est une grande presqu'île dans
le nord où il fait sans doute très froid
et donc là il ya quelque chose qui se
dégage de froid et de style ici au début
des années soixante dix il a encore en
transition dans son style où il commença
à mincir sa couche picturale et à
éclaircir ses couleurs mais on voit
vraiment classe et pas encore abouti il
recherche encore quelle est sa manière
de peindre est calé son geste surtout
[Musique]
alors marine je voulais aussi qu'on
allait voir ses toiles là bas parce que
la bagna une lumière différente aussi la
lumière je crois c'était très important
pour de vrai elles sont très
intéressantes parce que on arrive à
percevoir comment debré saisi la lumière
on arrive à percevoir l'atmosphère de
ces tableaux qui ont tous été
probablement réalisé le soir ces soirs
d'été en norvège où la nuit ne tombe
jamais vraiment debré dit que le jour ne
finit pas de mourir et c'est assez beau
et je trouve qu'on perçoit très bien ici
ce ciel un peu entre chien et loup et
les paysages c'était aussi quelque chose
que debray adoré il les ressent t il
essayer de mettre sur la toile ce que ça
lui inspirer en fait il voulait en
premier sur la toile les émotions qu'ils
ressentaient face au paysage
donc ce n'est pas de la peinture qui
reproduit la réalité c'est une peinture
qui reproduit ses sensations à lui en
réaction à la vue d'un paysage et pour
autant les norvégiens visiblement
reconnaissez les paysages au travers de
ses oeuvres c'est aussi pour ça qu'il
est extrêmement connu et adulé là bas
c'est ça ils retranscrivent est très
bien les sensations par exemple la
végétation qui lui au soleil après une
petite averse dans la presse norvégienne
en tout cas j'ai lu beaucoup de
journalistes qui ont donné cette image
là pour décrire les tables debré et
comment se fait-il que cet immense
reconnaissance qu'ils avaient en norvège
était un petit peu moindre ici en france
oui debré ne choisissez pas son camp
entre l'abstraction et la figuration ce
qui était gênant en france mais qui ce
qui ne semblait pas de l'être en norvège
[Musique]
alors on l'a vu e debril adoré la
lumière il aimait aussi le blanc
finalement et ça paraît un petit peu fou
mais le blanc c'est pas si simple à
rendre sur une toile en fait non il ya
beaucoup de peintres figuratifs qui ont
essayé de représenter la neige de
représenter un paysage enneigé comme
monnaies par exemple à la fin du 19e
siècle
debré quant à lui réussit très bien à
donner l'impression d'un paysage enneigé
on n'est pas du tout dans un paysage
mimétique ou réaliste on est dans un
paysage ressenti ça veut dire quoi très
concrètement ce parce que quoi il ya un
peu de matière d un peu de courbe
c'est ça les simples nuances de couleurs
et les simples relief de matières vous
suffisent pour imaginer des collines
enneigées des montagnes dans le
brouillard ou alors un éclat de soleil
qui donne une couleur rosée à la neige
donc c'est tout est dans le ressenti
avec olivier debré et tout est suggéré
plutôt que montrer merci beaucoup marine
pour cet éclairage
merci à vous et maintenant je vous
emmène découvrir toujours en avant
première une autre salle d'exposition de
ce centre
[Musique]
nous voici maintenant dans la nef la
partie la plus ancienne du centre
puisque c'est là qu'ils étaient
installés
l'école des beaux-arts un lieu au volume
immense et qui s'offrent aux regards des
passants
grâce à ses grandes baies vitrées pour
l'ouverture du centre la nef est devenu
l'écrin d'une chambre d'huile un procédé
technique qui sert à la réalisation de
photos notamment par le grand artiste
norvégien air barclays un procédé que
public ne voit que très rarement
nous nous avons eu la chance d'être là
au moment où cette grande mare d'eau et
d'huile a pris forme
regardez
[Musique]
un reflet qui donnent le vertige
quelques centimètres d'eau et d'huile
qui paraissent 11 m voici l'installation
de mer barclays
ça donne un aspect ambiguïté parce que
c'est bien sûr phase de réflexion
parfait et en quelque façon peut-être
envie quand même et en même temps çà çà
çà çà çà craint un immense
bild ces volets en profondeur un énorme
et voilà c'était le jeu entre le de
l'artiste ne pouvait pas rêver mieux que
la nef du cc cod pour accueillir son
oeuvre une surface de 26 mètres sur 8
près d'un an de conception plusieurs
semaines de réalisation en tout 3000
litres de liquide verser de l'eau
d'abord puis une fine pellicule d'huile
qui va tout recouvrir
l'artiste réalise ce genre d'oeuvre
depuis 28 ans avec à chaque fois la même
angoisse au moment de la finition
bien sûr de défendre hausse paraissent
quand même stressant amène voilà parce
que travaillant avec des l'équipe du
prend quand même des risques
on peut avoir des fuites il ya plein de
choses que ça peut passer
le beh je fais en armes et pas de minium
c'est tout ce sommet en plusieurs
parties vous voyez le ça s'apprend
parfaitement à l'espace et avec le
liquide dedans on va s'il ya des
imperfections c'est la hauteur sont pas
bonnes et tout ça et s'il faut dire que
ça fait au millimètre bien sûr c'est
très très difficile au revoir et
barclays a réalisé une trentaine
d'installations dans le monde dans tous
types de lieux parfois a vécu les mêmes
du sang il adore l'harmonie de la nef et
a hâte de découvrir la réaction du
public
une fois les rideaux ouverts pour que la
surprise soit totale
cela valait bien la peine de garder ce
secret jusqu'au bout
merci beaucoup par barclays d'être avec
nous dans cette jolie nef
c'est l'une de vos chambres nuit vous en
ont installé un petit peu partout et
généralement le public peut pas être
toujours les voir là pourquoi vous avez
vous lu que le public voit votre chambre
de ville parce que comme l'a justement
vous savez dit l'espace c'est quand même
formidable et avec une très grande
hauteur et moi j'ai trouvé qu'ils
étaient c'est vraiment un espace idéal
pour faire voir à public est vraiment de
l'installation de même ce non pas
seulement
pas seulement les photos voilà ça permet
d'avoir une valorisation de
l'architecturé aps une un beau vertiges
ou si c'est ça exactement
on a eu une oeuvre qui est un petit peu
au milieu de nulle part c'est une oeuvre
d'olivier debré pourquoi elle est la
7ème alors ça fait 48 ans en hockey moi
j'étais étudiant en histoire de l'art à
bergen et le premier galeriste quelques
jeux comme n'y avait cette petite un
tableau dans sa collection et je le vis
là et je trouvais vraiment génial ça m'a
beaucoup touché
jean m'a donné envie vraiment de faire
d'eux des choses de larmes à même de
devenir artiste en vol c'est tout a
démarré d'une oeuvre d'olivier debré oui
on peut dire ça en quelque sorte
merci beaucoup pas remarqué d'avoir été
avec nous on va les retrouver arnaud qui
est dans le troisième grand espace
d'exposition de ce centre la galerie
noir et il est entouré de plein de
jeunes artistes venus de norvège
eux aussi
we do is nous sommes dans la galerie
noir un espace dédié à la création
contemporaine et cette galerie accueille
pour le moment l'exposition in landes
elle rassemble le travail de onze
artistes venus de norvège pour en parler
je suis avec et le district aisne du
service des expositions parlez nous un
peu de cette exposition in landes
c'est le résultat d'un an et demi de
travail il cette exposition c'est une
véritable aventure
effectivement nous sommes partis en
norvège à la découverte de ces artistes
de leur travail des lieux même dans
lesquels il travaillait pour un petit
peu revenir ici à tour avec une odeur
une sensation de la norvège alors très
concrètement avec des oeuvres qui nous
sont arrivés directement issu du paysage
comme ça et qui viennent s'installer
dans l'exposition mais aussi des oeuvres
qu'on a produites spécifiquement pour
cette exposition est donc elodie tous
les médias sont rassemblés absolument
tous je crois la photo la peinture la
sculpture la performance et le son sont
présentés dedans vous avez voulu une
diversité
alors oui c'était vraiment le parti pris
de départ puisque on s'est rendu compte
assez vite que cette scène était très
diverse et on a voulu cette exposition à
l'image de cette scène
merci je vous propose de découvrir un
reportage sur deux artistes de cette
exposition in hand to rivera nes et inas
commis le virus un reportage réalisé en
norvège images de grégoire quechua
sous ses airs bucoliques la norvège est
un pays en pleine ébullition sur le plan
artistique
oslo n'est pas qu'une ville calme et
ordonnée elle cache aussi de vos petits
secrets des ateliers aux allures de
squat il c'est dans l'un d'entre eux que
travail itt nasreen levis us d'asti
siens et vidéaste il réalise des
performances comme ce dialogue vidéo
retranscrire musique
[Musique]
j'aime travailler avec la réalité qui
nous est accessible mais d'un autre côté
aussi pour la rendre irréel comme de la
science fiction lui donner un côté
imaginaire mais chaque chose est
connecté au réel a aujourd'hui à nos
problèmes d'une certaine façon guerre il
y aura une sculpture un muscle gonflable
qui va entourer le bâtiment d'une
certaine façon le tenir à des taux est
tombé à l'arc
ce sera un muscle noir pas rouge un
muscle abstrait en fait de tubes au flag
de plastique au 20 mars
autres artistes accueillis à tour tôt
rivera naissent ici en performance à
sydney
[Musique]
inclassable cette astucieuse revisite un
mythe nordique celui du troll elle
change son apparence et sa voix et se
produit partout dans le monde pour elle
le personnage du troll est universel
[Musique]
j'aime mes matières plastiques
j'aime jouer avec la réalité
la rendre plus abstraite créer une sorte
de réalité en dehors des normes
j'aime déformé mon propre corps j'aime
les grosses mains les gros pied les gros
ventre est à l'aise
[Musique]
la spécialité de tori des performances
in situ son repérage au ccc au délà
marqué et la date de tours est notée en
gros dans son agenda
iron tour je suis déjà venu à tour il y
à un mois voir le bâtiment pour la
première fois et j'ai été soufflé c'est
fou d'arriver dans un lieu tout neuf qui
n'est même pas encore nés
[Musique]
tout sent le neuf tout est immaculé ga
de salir tout ça sow
le public du ccc audi est donc prêt
nous sommes de retour dans la galerie
noir est derrière nous le muscle une
oeuvre digne menace comme je vis juste
qui englobe tout le bâtiment rayonner
oui c'est une oeuvre un peu folle on
s'est dit qu'on n'allait pas se limiter
à l'intérieur de la galerie noir pour
cette exposition et on est un petit peu
sortis des murs du cc cod avec une
sculpture d'abord de thierry la salle
clip que vous verrez sur le parvis est
ici se muscle puisque c'est comme ça
qu'on appelle entre nous cette grande
sculpture abstraite composé de ballon
gonflé à l'air et qui s'inscrivent sur
tout le contour arrière du bâtiment dans
ce qu'on appelle les galeries
transparente qui est un espace qui est
très particulier puisque enfin en fait
il est visible 24 heures sur 24 7 jours
sur 7 depuis l'extérieur
alors j'imagine que vous êtes dit tout
est possible pour ses verreries noires
alors on se le dit jusqu'à une certaine
limite c'est vrai que dans un centre
d'art on al'avantage de travailler en
direct avec les artistes donc de pouvoir
imaginer des projets complètement fou là
ça a été le cas mais bien sûr on a
toujours les limites du bâtiment d de
multiples critères de faisabilité
merci elodie et avoue héloïse
[Musique]
merci beaucoup arnaud et on termine
cette émission spéciale au centre de
création contemporaine olivier debré
avec vous à lens julien laferrière un
petit mot sur votre ressenti aujourd'hui
ça fait 40 ans que vous menez ce projet
de centre de création contemporaine vous
et vos équipes
votre sentiment aujourd'hui c'est quoi
ce même sentiment mon avis que beaucoup
de tourangeaux c'est que c'est attendu
depuis longtemps qu'ils avaient envie
qu'on parle d'eux j'avais envie d'avoir
un lieu qui qui les réunit c'est que le
monde entier avec ses artistes viennent
visiter cette ville qu'est ce que vous
lui souhaitez à votre centre comme on
dit toujours longue vie belle vie avec
beaucoup de passage beaucoup d'artistes
étrangers qui viennent parce que c'est
important pour les tourangeaux
d'abord il ya toujours des artistes
étrangers en touraine depuis l'histoire
depuis toute l'histoire de ma vinci
aujourd'hui la deuxième ils sont déjà là
les artistes
il ya déjà une vingtaine d'artistes
scandinaves qui est de partout des états
unis de londres qui sont là et puis
voilà ils sont au travail pour
l'ouverture mais ils sont prêts à
rencontrer les visiteurs
on donne rendez vous au public à partir
de 15 heures les portes du centre de
création contemporaine olivier debré
ouvre dès 15h cet après midi et demain
dès 11h 30
merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi cette
émission dans un instant vous
retrouverez votre journal d'information
régionale très bon week-end à tous
[Musique]